i was browsing the david pakman show
reddit discussion forum this morning a
david pakman.com slash reddit there has
been a significant influx path of
respectful conservatives wanting to have
rational discussions about political
issues and given that reddit can be such
a cesspool of trolling i'm actually and
part of it is about the moderators
managing the situation well we have very
good bipartisan discussion happening on
the reddit discussion forum that's
honestly great to hear because it's nice
that we're able to welcome in focus on
the other side indeed who can actually
have a reasonable discussion with us i
am completely open and want to have
reasonable discussion with people with
opposing views let's go through a few of
the popular discussions that I spotted
one is a theory about Paul Ryan's leaked
voicemail I won't read the entire thing
to you it's a very very elaborate and
long theory now but I encourage you to
check it out also from our reddit
discussion forum the idea that it was
Russia that may have wiretapped trump
tower if indeed anybody did interesting
discussion happening there also from the
reddit discussion forum someone asking
for an explanation as to why the Muslim
ban is unconstitutional this is a great
example of someone saying I'm not
looking to start a fight and I'm not
saying it's a good idea I just want to
understand why is it unconstitutional
and a discussion is forming about that
if you have thoughts on it go to david
pakman.com slash reddit and participate
and even though i'm not a conservative i
still had questions as to whether the
second javelin refugee ban was
unconstitutional so that's a very fair
point absolutely also from the reddit
discussion forum what should david's
middle name be clearly the aftershocks
of the middle name controversy that took
place last week still being felt on
reddit and lastly i should look at those
comments everyone deserves the middle
name everyone deserves access to a
middle name that our exhibit very clever
yeah the republican talking point on
health care okay and lastly david pakman
is doing a DNA test what do you think he
will find out my theory is that in at on
pakman is actually only his half-brother
one commenter saying Lewis is day
its father yes I am doing a DNA test pad
is doing a DNA test we're going to have
a DNA expert join us to explain and
interpret the results we're probably six
to eight weeks away from that still it
sounds about right would you be
surprised to learn that lewis is
actually your father I would because I'm
nine months older than him so that would
really be interesting what it would do
for her understanding of the linear
nature of the time would really be would
really be mind-blowing so breakthrough
it would be a medical breakthrough of
sorts yeah all right join us david
pakman.com slash read it over 3,000
strong now